this is a production of cornell
university
well thanks dollar welcome all from
smoky california
it's uh another beautiful sunny but
smoky day and uh
really unfortunately we can't meet in
person i was kind of hoping to see some
nice
colorful east coast scenes here in the
fall but we're going to be doing this
all at home at
our our new world so
today i'm going to talk about uh
basically the plant microbiome and you
know the microbiome science is really
hot these days
but not that many people look at the
bacteria and other microbes on the
surface of plants and that's really what
i want to try to get you excited about
today
i'm going to talk about epiphytes
microbes that live on the surface of
plants and
really i think they've got a lot of
interesting features they're certainly
very pertinent to plant pathology but
we're going to be talking about their
context in a number of different
settings
now i'm going to study mostly epiphytic
bacteria we're going to be talking about
those that live on the surface of
healthy plants for the most part
so this is images a typical image of a
leaf surface this
tunnel-like object you're looking down
as a stomata
they're very small obviously on the
surface are these large
numbers of small blobs these are the
bacterial cells
this is very typical of all healthy
plants they're somewhere between
10 000 and about 10 million of these
kind of bacteria found per square
centimeter of leaf
so basically edible plants non-edible
plants they're all going to have very
similar densities
plants are very abundant on the plant
obviously on the planet obviously so
there's about avogadro's number of
bacteria when you consider all of the
plants uh and all of the bacteria that
would be considered on them
this is probably an underestimate
because it really been very little look
of
microbes that are on plants in tropical
areas and it's
very likely that microbes on tropical
plants that are wet all the time
are likely to be even higher than what
we're going to talk about today
now much of the study of epiphytes has
been driven by uh plant disease
it's been known for a while that uh
pathogens especially plant pathogenic
bacteria
exist as epiphytes on healthy plants
before inciting disease
and in fact we can often predict disease
based on the population size of these
bacteria that
are essentially inoculant can eventually
enter and cause
disease and a couple of examples of
those are
bacterial brown spot of being in the
upper right and fire blight on the lower
right
these are both classic examples of how
pest management is
is uh attuned to the population of these
microbes
on the leaf because low populations of
microbes on the plant there's very
little likelihood
that even if environmental conditions
became favorable
that disease would ever occur but
everything else being equal higher
populations will increase the likelihood
of disease
so again this has been driven uh a lot
by plant pathology
and the system is very very much like uh
human skin we all have staph aureus on
our under
on our skin and disease is really
unlikely unless we do have an oculum
present
now other groups of microbes that get a
little less attention that
i think are quite interesting and very
important is
uh bacteria that can't catalyze ice
formation
this work that i worked on long ago
bacteria that catalyze ice are very
prominent on plants in fact that's
basically the only place you would find
these microbes
and these are quite unique in that they
have the ability to catalyze ice and
water that would otherwise super cool
you see in the graph on the right hand
side
the ability of water to super cool water
does not freeze at zero degrees
celsius to form ice in fact it will
supercool to temperatures
easily and even as cold as around -40
but these bacteria can catalyze ice at a
temperature of about
minus one or minus and because of that
water cannot remain liquid to those cold
temperatures whether that otherwise
would
these are very important to plant
because plants are mostly water
and the bacteria that live on the plants
then
limit the ability of that water within
the plants to super cool and when ice
forms
we get a mechanical damage to the plant
that we call frost damage
and again it's because of the bacteria
that plants do in fact freeze because
without the bacteria present plants
themselves can easily reciprocal to
around minus six minus
seven degrees celsius uh the water in
those plants will remain liquid super
cool but in the presence of the bacteria
they will in fact
nucleate and freeze at a temperature of
around minus one to minus two
and that's typically where we start to
see frost damage in plants is around 28
29 degrees fahrenheit
minus two celsius and again it's the
population size of these bacteria that
drive
the uh the freezing temperature of the
plants
we have very high population sizes of
bacteria
the plants will not supercool more than
two around minus two
but as we decrease the population sizes
of the bacteria on the plant
the plant has the ability to super cool
and approaches
a temperature of around minus five or
minus six
when they're going to start to freeze
because of other
substances within the plant that cause
nucleation
so if you actually get up and wash
plants freeze you'll see images like you
see in the upper left where
these are citrus leaves i took picture
in the morning around
minus four degrees celsius out you see
dew drops on the leaves that are still
liquid
but in this darkened area ice has
started to form and you can actually see
the dew drops are starting to
look icy presumably because a particular
bacterium at that site
catalyzed isolation and that ice is now
going to start spreading and within a
few minutes
this cluster of leaves would have been
frozen so again bacteria limit the super
cooling ability of plants
and thereby cause frost damage and
that's also one of the justifications
for a lot of the work that we're going
to talk about today is can we modify the
communities
after knowing enough how they form to
reduce the population sizes of either
pathogens
or in this case ice nucleating bacteria
now these bacteria not only are they
interesting and important on plants but
they're also
actually quite important in a whole
global precipitation cycle
it turns out for various reasons the
bacteria that catalyze ice are most
common on the leaf surfaces
a little later on i'm going to talk
about the escape of bacteria from leaves
to go up into the air very abundant
about a million or so per square meter
per hour
leave leaf surfaces fly up in the air
if you had clouds above you you would
see that most of the water in those
clouds are super cool
water droplets they're very cold fog if
you would
and these super cold water droplets are
small they don't
fall out of the cloud because they're
too small but if ice starts to form in
this case by a bacterial cell
interacting with these drops of water
the drops of water will start to
coalesce and form larger and larger
particles of ice
and eventually those ice crystals get
big enough that they're too large to be
supported in the cloud and they start
falling out
they always start falling as ice and if
it's warm on the way down it melts and
we call it rain
it's cold all the way down we call it
snow but much of the precipitation
in the temperate part of the world
except for very close to the equator
is driven by this ice forming process in
the clouds and
because the bacteria are again
emigrating from plants into the air
they are now thought to be some of the
major participants in this process
certain minerals and other things can
also do it but these bacteria
because they're so efficient at
catalyzing ice
at a warm temperature are thought to be
particularly important
and for those of you who are skiers or
boarders uh
these ice nucleating bacteria including
pseudomonas serenity the most common and
important ice nucleator
are used to make artificial snow they
grow up sit them on a certainty freeze
dry and add it to the water that's
blowing up in the air
so that you get ice forming in the air
rather than
freezing rain if you would so it's
become a huge industrial process
some million pounds or so a year of
freeze-dried bacteria are made
for artificial snow i wish i could say i
made a penny out of it but
hopefully pseudomonas reindeer making
the world a little better
in that context so again what are the
bacteria doing we saw
nucleaters and pathogens but most
bacteria aren't either
but moldy bacteria that live on plants
are thought to be important in
protecting plants against other
pathogens
this is quite indisputable and a classic
example of that phenomenon would be
fire blight of pears and apples and the
presence of other bacteria that do not
cause disease
being able to protect against pathogens
that do
in this typical scenario the flowers of
an apple in this case
are emerging most plants as they emerge
into the world are almost sterile
without any bacteria in this case
they stigma of the surface of the pistol
is
certainly free of pathogen if you become
inoculated with a pathogen shown that
little
red cells here they can grow rapidly on
a somatic stigmatic surface
get the high populations that can
eventually invade the flower
and eventually cause disease but we know
though that if we were to inoculate that
stigma soon after it emerged with a
non-pathogen
it will grow to high numbers as well and
then if the
immigration of the pathogen were to
occur there's limited opportunity for it
to grow because of
either competition or anabiosis and as
population size remains sufficiently low
that disease
is unlikely and this is one of the
the classic examples of biological
control where
here you see one of the strains we found
pseudomonas fluorescens a506
being applied to the flowers of these
trees
early in the spring so that the process
of colonization if you would is
accelerated to offer some protection
against the pathogen
and there are other bacteria and yeast
that are now being used
for a similar mode so let's talk a
little
bit about how and why do bacteria grow
on plants
and part of it is simply diet they have
to have carbon to grow
and it seems like the abundance of
various carbon containing compounds is
the limiting factor for the growth of
these microbes
we found some years ago that in fact the
bacterial numbers are limited by the
amount of sugar and that plants vary a
lot
in the amount of these nutrients that
are found on the plant
sounds like cucumbers and tomatoes and
beans are much higher than peas and corn
when you look at either the number of
amount of sugar that's found on a plant
and the bacterial numbers that can
result and i talk a lot about sugar
because sugar does seem to be the
primary carbon source on most plants
if you look at bean leaves as an example
sucrose glucose and fructose are by far
the most abundant carbon containing
compounds
you have some organic acids and
amino acids and all but together there
is not a lot
there's only a few micrograms per leaf
of these carbon
but if you add it up that's about enough
to generate about 100 million bacteria
on a leaf and that's about the
population size that we typically see
so it seems to be a carbon but not a
nitrogen limited situation
but more importantly and what's going to
be central to what we're going to talk
about today is the fact that this carbon
does not seem to be distributed
uniformly around the leaf
now using a sugar biosensor in this case
for the
sugar fructose a fructose responsive
promoter linked to an unstable
gfp we could examine the ability of
bacteria to
be consuming sugar so if we put
a biosensor that we had grown up in the
lab
containing that gene fusion growing
without any fructose onto a leaf
come back two hours after inoculation
you can see that
initially they were non-fluorescent but
within two hours
many if not most of the cells we applied
to the leaf have become green
fluorescent
but if you come back and look 24 hours
after we had inoculated
and i you just have to believe me that
in fact there's still cells all over
this leaf there's only cells in a few
local areas
where in fact the cells remain green
it's an unstable
gfp has to continue to be made to be
remained fluorescent
and it appears then that there is at
least a little bit of sugar all over the
leaf surface but
abundant sugar or replenishing sugar is
really only present
in a few locations so we kind of use
this as an
image of a nutritional desert if you
would there's
a little resource everywhere but only a
few oasis if you would
where the sugars become quite abundant
this helps explain what you see when you
take lots of images of a leaf surface
and one of my former students did a lot
of studies of basically
microbes on the leaf and what you'll see
on this image and here's some stomata
for studies comparison and
many parts of the leaf are rather
impoverished there's little or no
bacteria present
but you'll see occasionally these large
aggregates of bacteria
some call them biofilm but they're large
piles of bacteria wood in this image
there's probably
10 000 bacteria in this particular image
they're not very numerous but they are
very very large numbers of microbes that
occur in these particular sites just to
some
numbers to that look at the red bars
here
this is the number of cells in a local
area we're going to call an aggregate
from single cells
up to thousands of cells in aggregate
and how many there were
on a log scale you'll see that there's
thousands of sites where there's only
one or a few cells in a given location
and only a few places where these
large aggregates occur but if you look
at the red balls on the lower
graph where you look at the cumulative
proportion of the
population that occurred as a function
of the
sign of aggregate in which they occurred
and let's just use 100 cells as
a cut off you'll see that more than half
of all the microbes in a cell
on a leaf were in fact in these large
aggregates larger than about 100
cells and so in many ways it brings me
very much like
distribution of humans on the on the
planet the united states
little circles here represent the size
of cities
from over here where i live in
california you fly
toward new york you're going to pass
over chicago after flying over the
flyover states
and you look down you're going to see
lots and lots of farms as you go across
certainly in the midwest
but not until you see a city are you
going to really see large numbers of
people
and it always reminded me of california
which is a huge
city huge state lots of forests and
deserts and all but it's also the most
urbanized state in the united states
97 of californians live in cities
greater than 100
000 people including myself so again
most people in the world tend to live in
cities now and
life in the city is very very different
than where i grew up
in a country up in oregon and we're
going to talk now about
the differences of being part of these
groups
life in the city versus life in the
country and the first thing you
can recognize is the fact that looking
at the cells whether they're alive or
dead
uh after exposure to a typical daylight
condition so
wet night today is sunny and dry in the
daytime
and look at the the yellow line
again and this is going to be the the
proportion of the population that is in
uh
that are living and you can see that all
of these more solitary cells for the
most part are dead and it's really only
in these cells that are
in these large aggregates larger than
about 100 cells
and in fact those cells are live
so life is tough in the country if you
would if you're in a micro
and it's not only important for you to
probably grow up
amongst other cells on a leaf surface
probably
driven by this local availability of
sugar that's coming from the leafs
but in fact immigration successful
immigration to the leaf is also
very much favored by the presence of
these aggregates
this is important in issues such as food
safety
we've done a bit of work on salmonella
human pathogen
something you don't want to see on
plants that you're eating but is often
there
it turns out that the salmonella itself
is a very poor colonist of plants
when it is put on by itself it
quite quickly dies but if we were to
immigrate salmonella onto cells
hunt leaves and look to see whether it
landed in a
in a barren part of the leaf where there
were not other bacteria
or whether it had landed amongst these
aggregates that we had already
established on the leaf
you'll see that it was really only those
cells that landed amongst other
organisms
that were alive most of these solitary
cells were in fact
dead so i think this is
image is really what you should think
about when you think of life on a leaf
that
much of the leaf is relatively poorly
colonized probably because
for unknown reasons there isn't very
much nutrient there
but where nutrients are available the
microbes can make relatively
large aggregations or
biofilms if you would here you can see
the individual cells and they're kind of
in this
cocoon if you would of extracellular
polysaccharide
if it was at all humid it is probably
holding on to water it's probably a
a slime pile if you would and again
life within that slime pile is probably
very different from life out here where
any individual cell is very unlikely to
have made enough of a
modification of its environment in a
biofilm if you would
to benefit from it whereas being part of
a group
there would be this cooperation and
benefit from having others also
modifying that environment but looking
at that image immediately
made me think of quorum simpson growing
uh paradigm in microbiology where
we used to think of uh microbial cells
especially bacteria which are single
cells
and being rather individualistic in
their behavior
but it turns out that microbes do have
very different behaviors when they're
part of a group than when they're
solitary and this process is uh known as
quorum sensing
where the mechanism then driving it is
where individual bacteria are all
bacteria individually produce small
numbers of
small molecules which are released from
the cell
if the cells are relatively solitary
those
signal molecules basically diffuse away
and the cells know that they're alone
because they can't perceive their signal
molecule
but if the cells end up having neighbors
especially neighbors of their own type
which are all making the same signal
molecule the local concentration of the
signal molecule is going to increase
and they they can then re-perceive that
signal molecule
by a variety of mechanisms and use that
then as a signal
to change the transcription of genes
which are
important to be regulated differently
when they are part of a group
than when they are solitary and in the
case of cinema serenity our
favorite microbe one of the traits that
we know to be regulated in this way
is motility it turns out that when the
cells have the ability to sense a signal
molecule and when they're in part of a
group
they are not modal but mutants which are
blocked in the ability to produce a
signal molecule as you see on this
right hand uh image the cells have this
in this case swarming ability able to
move around actively
and in that case it turns out that the
ability to signal
and tell themselves that they're part of
a group actually
reduces the virulence of
cinematoserenity because
the wild-type strain makes less disease
than a mutant
presumably because it's not able to move
around on the leaf surface
find its way to these sites where
nutrients would be available and
probably also
enter into the plant active motility
does seem to be something you'd want to
do in that kind of a scenario where out
on a
nutritional desert and need to find the
right places if you would to live
but it also calls into question how
much fidelity there is to this system
and that
microbes that don't live in the world in
pure cultures in the
case of the leaf surface certainly
there's usually a quite a variety of
microbes that live on leaf
the upper picture here shows a typical
leaf washing plated out and you'll see
a variety of microbes epiphytes tend to
be very colorful
they're often red or pink or yellow part
of that is due to the
sunscreen effect that you get from being
pigmented
but pseudomonas ringi often had many
other neighbors
and when we look at the neighbors of
pseudomonas regional leaf we find that
around 12 percent of other species
produce the same signal molecule the
three
the same three oxoloxanoel homocerine
lactone one of the more
quorum sensing signal molecules that
bacteria use
so around 12 percent make the same
signal as cerinvi
but around eight percent have a
mysterious ability to inhibit the
production or perception
of the signal molecule by sediment
australia
well given that we were very interested
to know well
could these neighbors then be
influencing the
virulence of pseudomonas maggie because
this virulence is in fact
directly driven by the quorum sensing
mechanism
and the answer was definitely yes that
uh
show an example this strain or when you
strain ft1 which is one that made a
large amount of the
same signal molecule with cinema surgery
and i might
note that for whatever reason they made
about a hundred times more
than pseudomonas did in its own right
and look at though
this simple express spray and pretty
experiment we use
the inoculation of the minus 3d by
itself count how many lesions 35 lesions
when inoculated together with the wendy
and the amount of infections went way
down
and when we we couldn't because of this
competition for signaling but in fact
when we blocked the ability of the
awning strain to produce the signal by
introducing
an ahl lactinase which basically
destroyed the signal molecule
its ability to grow but not able to
produce the
signal molecule then you see that its
presence without the signaling
capability
had again no effect on the pathogen so
it did seem like the overwhelming
presidency
was the reason why that neighbor could
in fact produce
signaling suggesting that we might be
able to exploit this phenomenon by
having competitors that could produce
signal molecules who inhibit the growth
and variance if you would of pathogens
for which signaling is important
but the opposite is also true and that
we had strains that
interfered with pseudomonas ringing
signaling
pseudomonas by itself made some lesions
we made a lot more infection when
the in the signaling interference strain
was co-inoculated with syringe again a
mutant of that strain which blocked its
ability to interfere
now we see no real effect of its
presence so in fact
neighbors of cinema syringe can actually
increase disease
so facilitation of disease by neighbors
on a plant is also
quite possible and it gets even more
complicated because it turns out that
plants themselves
can perceive the signal molecules that
these potential pathogens
are producing and it may be that many
plants are in fact
actually listening into the signaling
that pathogens are using to
gear up to express virulence traits
to infect that plant and we now know
that the plants might be
anticipating disease by listening in
and appropriately regulating their
potential responses to the pathogen
well we've been interested in what are
the adaptations needed for bacteria to
live in and on plants
uh the bacteria live on plants are very
distinct from those in the soil and
we're going to come back to that in a
minute
but basically what does it take to live
on a plant at least today in california
i hear it's raining in ithaca
but here in california it's sunny and
warm and smoky
microbes on the leaf surface have many
stresses they've got to deal with
desiccation
and other things that are going on but
plants these same pathogens certainly
can enter
and start to multiply within a plant
and within the tissues the apoplasts
have probably different requirements for
exploitation of that plant than those
that need it to grow on this leaf
well pseudomonas serenity strained b720a
the one we've done a lot of work on over
the years was one of the first to be
sequenced by
jgi and we've been able to do exploit
that to look at the transcriptomics of
this to really look to see
what are those traits that are at least
expressed
uh on the leaf surface and tyler when he
was a student actually looked at
what was the importance of those traits
in actual fitness but i'll let him tell
you about that
in another story but we looked at the
the gene expression of the bacteria
under various conditions in the
laboratory and
the first disappointment was the fact
that basically
no condition that we could look at
in the culture with low nitrogen
peroxide present the kind of conditions
that we
thought might mimic the leaf surface the
gene expression
patterns were very very different from
what we would see on the leaf
so it kind of suggests that much of what
we've been trying to do
in the laboratory for since microbiology
started isn't really
very appropriate because there's a very
plant specific pattern of gene
expression that we can now get at with
the
transcriptomics that we're going to talk
about now
so i don't just highlight a few of the
things that we saw by looking at the
expression of all the genes of cinema
serengeti
first in the epithetic conditions and
those are in the red bars what are the
traits that were
particularly prominently expressed on
the on the leaf surface
flagellar motility basically anything
about motility and chemotaxis were
certainly upregulated on the leaf
surface compared to
any kind of condition in the interior or
on any kind of a culture medium
and a couple of other things that really
struck us were things like uh tryptophan
uh synthesis and i'm gonna come back to
talk about that in a minute
one of the things that we're typically
strongly upregulated when they're inside
and that's going to be the green virus
here
various toxins and there's been a lot of
interest in various toxins made by
uh cinnamon cereal various phytotoxins
sergio myosin cerealite
these were certainly upregulated on the
inside of the plant but
also on the surface suggesting that
these toxins may
also play a role in perhaps changing the
chemical or physical environment of the
leaf surface
one that was really quite striking on
the other hand were the genes involved
in the production of various compatible
solutes
things like trail of a sugar that's
able to help cells tolerate water stress
and yes we saw those up regulating on
the leaf surface and the red bars
but they were very very strongly up
regulated also on the interior
suggesting very strongly that the
interior of a leaf is actually quite dry
and i think most of us going into this
kind of a study suggested
that the interior i've always thought it
was kind of you know
moist and sugary but it's not it's it's
quite dry
air penetrates into the leaf to allow
the gas exchange for photosynthesis
and we're going to talk about another
tree here in just a second string a
factor the biosurfactant is made by the
bacteria
made both on the interior and the
exterior of the plant
we did find though that many of the
trees that are
expressed by pseudomonas seed were
preferentially expressed
either on the interior of the plant or
on the surface but
i just want to follow up on that with
two traits that
made interesting stories one with
tryptophan uh biosynthesis
and one is this syringe factor and
there's biosurfactant
let's start with the tryptophan story
it turns out that basically almost every
microbe that you ever recover from a
plant
has the ability to produce the plant
hormone three endo acetic acid
it's very striking that very few
bacteria from other habitats have this
ability
uh but virtually all plant microbes do
and that that leads us back to
tryptophan tryptophan is the ultimate
source for
three and all acetic acid which you see
in the middle of this pathway
and various plant pathogens have the
ability to convert tryptophan into oia
avia this intermediate
endulocetamide but we find that most
non-pathogens and a lot of pathogens as
well
use this central pathway from indole
pyruvic acid to endoacetylide
into iaa but the real question is why
did the bacteria
all produce oxygen and this is just
document that no matter what taxes you
look at
almost all of them make some and many
make an awful lot
of three and all acetic acid
it turns out that they make enough that
they actually account for some of the
phenotypes that we typically associate
with the plant itself things like
flour and fruit obsession classical
oxen-mediated
phenotype and a phenomenon we've been
studying a lot because of its
commercial importance in california is
this phenomenon called
fruit russeting where we know that the
presence of high numbers of oxen
producing bacteria on the fruit with a
very small
centimeter or someone in diameter in the
early spring
uh change the apparently change that the
the development of the epidermal cells
of the fruit such that
they die early and produces quirky dead
cell reset that we see on the surface of
the fruit
the fruit don't store quite as well they
don't look as
appealing to other consumers like you
see the fruit on the right an apartment
pair
uh so growers actually suffer
substantially
because of the lower value of these that
go into making baby foods rather than
going on the shelf again auxin can
also be used as a signaling molecule and
this has been well studied in
agrobacterium and others
it's not clear whether it's a signaling
molecule of its own right
and other plant associated bacteria but
there's some potential
but what i want to talk about with the
story of what i'm going to call resource
conversion
another reason why the bacteria would
make auxin
and we knew that producing oxygen was
very important to the microbes and that
when we made mutes of
this case of linear herbicola very
common epiphyte
uh to block its ability to produce
oxygen and we put a mutant mixture
a mutant unable to produce a signal with
the uh
wild type strain but the mixture on a
plant
came back various times after we put
them on a planet look at the
rate change in the ratio it started out
wild type and it increased dramatically
to favor the wild type after
a few generations on the plant
suggesting that
in fact it was very important to be
making oxen but why
well to think back again to the nutrient
story and
thinking that it looks like carbon does
limit the amount of growth that microbes
have on a plant
the simple model would be that by some
way the presence of oxygen produced from
production on leaf surface cause
nutrients to release
to be released from the inside of the
plant upon the leaf surface
again it has to cross the cuticle and
there would be different
ways in which that might be mediated
so we started up to test this model then
to see whether in fact
in the presence of auxin would the
bacteria see
more sugar does oxen production somehow
release
sugar onto the leaf surface and again
we're going to use biosensors that we
developed before in this case one for
the detection of sucrose
sucrose being the most abundant carbon
source on most plants
so we take a fr a sucrose responsive
promoter link in this case to a
promoter-less ice gene ice nucleation
genes
single genes are capable of for the
isonucleation phenotype
ice nucleation is a very very very
sensitive
uh i reporter gene because of ease for
which it's detected so we're going to
now look for
sucrose-dependent production of ice
nucleation in
a strain in which we would put this
reporter gene that whether
otherwise would not have been capable of
production of ice nuclei
and we came kept coming up with the
wrong answer so to speak
um you know supposed to have
anticipations but in this case a
depression is not
a ox in this case a synthetic oxen
nepali acetic acid
we actually see less ice nuclei
apparently the bacteria are seeing
less sucrose in the presence of the
auxin than they did
uh when there was no oxygen present
inclined they're more active than the
one with the green line so we did it
many times we always got the same answer
less apparent sucrose in the presence of
auxin
we already had the sensor for fructose
that i showed you before a gfp
reporter and there we see that in fact
in the presence of oxen we do
see apparently much more fructose being
made available in the presence of oxen
no oxen with oxen
so confusing but it made more sense when
we started to think about what's
actually
happening on a plant so go back to one
of the very early tables that i showed
you with there was
10 micrograms of sugar
on a typical bean leaf well a bean leaf
in the morning after a dew had formed
there might be
a milliliter or a dew that would form on
a leaf
and you think about what's the
concentration of that sugar that would
be present
it's going to be we're talking
milligrams per liter of nutrient
concentration just
tiny concentrations of these sugars
now the bacteria have to actively uptake
these sugars to be able to consume
and multiply and there are different
uptake mechanisms for disaccharides
than there are for monosaccharides like
fructose and glucose
so we asked whether the bacteria could
actually consume and grow
at the low concentrations of these
sugars that they would probably see
in the real world an answer was quite
obvious that they could consume fructose
at very very low
concentrations like 0.05 milligrams per
liter just
tiny amounts of sugar were enough for
them to
perceive and grow sucrose on the other
hand it took
10 to 100 times more sugar before they
could even
grow on that as a carbon source and
further support of that would be
measurement of the basically the
metabolic activity of the cells and the
same kind of
very low concentrations and we test that
with the
cell wall synthesis inhibitor
cycloserine like
like penicillin it will block cell wall
synthesis and thereby
kill the bacteria only if the cells are
in fact
growing and it turned out that yes
indeed
the cells are sensitive to cycloserine
at these very very low concentrations
whereas you can see with sucrose much
higher concentrations of sucrose were
needed before cells became sufficiently
metabolically active
trying to grow and were then poisoned by
a cycloserine
so it would seem then that in fact
carbon is in fact very limited on the
leaf surface but
that they are probably not directly
consuming sucrose they're probably
consuming primarily
these more easily consumable
glucose and fructose and that our work
didn't really
get to the point of showing but somehow
the presence of iaa is
going to activate these cell wall
invertases that are present in plants
that are now going to be making that
conversion to
convert sucrose into glucose and
fructose
there's a variety of these syllable
invertases
the various mutants that we've tested we
didn't find one particular one but it
would appear that there
is one of the many cellular inverters
that are in fact induced
by the presence of iaea
now another story i want to give you
again something that's happening that we
think on a very small scale on these is
the role of
biosurfactants and one of the
traits that many uh microbes that live
on plants have is the ability to produce
these bio surfactants these are
detergent like molecules amphipathic
molecules where we have typically a
polar head group usually some sort of a
peptide linked to a nasal chain
which is very detergent like very high
def very hydrophilic
head ceriufactin is one such bios effect
that is uh produced by
pseudomonas serenity and our work with
new
methods to detect biosurfactant
production in bacteria as a whole
revealed that
biophysical production was particularly
prominent among
bacteria on plants compared to other
kind of
settings like soil and water and so on
well what do these biosurfactants being
do certainly they might act as a
detergent to be wood and
and simply disperse water on this very
waxy surface
but we found actually that it seemed to
have two particular traits that are
even bacteria
and one is that it seems to be able to
alter the permeability of this waxy
cuticle that
covers most plants so again there's a
waxy cuticle made up of a variety of
materials
which blocks not only the loose loss of
water from the plant
but would also block the movement of any
kind of polar molecules like sugars up
onto the surface of the plant
now working with a group in germany uh
professor schreiber
you could peel off at the dermal peels
which would contain the cuticle put them
on the surface of a
basically tritiated water and we could
watch the diffusion of tritium
across that cuticle and again an intact
cuticle there's a very slow movement of
trivium but when we put then
bios effect on this case ring effect and
onto the surface of that cuticle
immediately the greater movement of the
tritium across that
cuticle increased so simplistically i
simply see it essentially dissolving
that cuticle as disrupting it in some
way
to make it more permeable to polar
molecules or maybe even water themselves
to probably very beneficial effect of
the bacteria
now one of the other interesting
features of a lot of these bio
surfactants including ceram is that
they're very hygroscopic that these
uh various groups on the polar end are
able to engage in hydrogen bonding with
water
and it makes it very very hygroscopic
and at high relative humidity
these materials will bind large volumes
of water
several times their mass and water are
bound by these types of material
so we immediately thought of this as
something that would be very beneficial
to a bacterium and we'd always thought
of desiccation stress being
perhaps one of the most important
stresses that microbes on a leaf would
face
these are drying much of the time and
they have to survive this
periodic and prolonged desiccation
now i mentioned these compatible
solutions before as cells
of all organisms experience low water
availability
they often accumulate these so-called
compatible solutes
and among the compatible solutes is the
amino acid proline
the more dry the cells would be the more
proline they're going to want to make
so gwen beatty developed a very nice
biosensor for water stress if you would
taking advantage of the fact that we
could examine
the expression of the pro-u one of the
regulators the proline biosynthesis
linked to again
a green fluorescent protein reporter
gene
the drier the cells the higher the
expression of prolene genes
and the greener the cells are going to
be so introducing this
reporter into a wild-type stream but
also a strain that was blocked
in its ability to produce a string
effect on the biosurfactant
we could then recover the cells after
different conditions on
dry leaves each one of these little dots
is how green
the individual cells were we're looking
at the greenness from left to right and
the fraction of cells exhibit
that greenness and you can see that as a
whole the wild type strains are much
less green than the mutant which is what
they
unable to accumulate the bios effect
so basically these cells are drier it
does appear then if there is sufficient
bios effect
made by the bacterium that they're
essentially making a small
aqueous zone if you would around the
bacteria by either
attracting water in the form of vapor
that would probably serve on the in the
leaf surface a laminar layer of
relatively humid air would surround a
dry leaf
that might be extracted as liquid water
onto the surface of bacteria
or it might actually hold on to water
when the leaf was eventually
intermittently wet but nonetheless it
does appear that it is a very important
survival
factor for the bacterium because
compared to the uh
wild-type strain mutants that were
blocked into production of
cerinofactin and then exposed to four or
five of these wet dry
patterns typical of a wet a day night
cycle
so that the mutant was much less capable
of survival compared to the wild-type
strain so again it looks like
a very localized wedding if you would of
the bacteria
the spring effect i'm shown by the balls
and tails here
are attracting enough water that the
bacterium is going to
benefit from that wetter location
so i'm going to finish by just a couple
of bigger issues so everything we've
talked about so far is happening
at a very small scale the world is a
very big place to a very tiny bacterium
and
everything that's important to that
bacteria is probably very
localized but the real question is how
do we get the microbes on the leaves
that we
see on the leaves and i mentioned before
that when plants
first emerge into the world they're
usually almost devoid of bacteria
here's a image from one of my thesis
some you can see how long ago
they're showing that all these different
kind of plants growing in wisconsin
there are very very few bacteria on the
plants early and the bacteria
then accumulate within a few days to a
week or two
to much much higher levels surprising
given that these all plants were
emerging through the soil
there was lots of soil-borne organisms
but in fact
they did not seem to colonize the plant
surface
and we recently did a study where we
looked at microbes that we recovered
from bean leaves and compared those to
soil organisms
near the bean plants in the field and
some rhizosphere microbes from the
same plants and we put them through that
typical
stressful condition that a plant would
see inoculated those leaf isolates for
example
let them grow under a wet leaf for a day
then let them dry measure how many
bacteria could grow up and survive
and then expose them to wet excuse me to
dry
conditions with uv light and see how
many could survive and again enumerate
how many microbes we saw
we then looked at it how what was the
fate of those cells compared what they
were when they were wet compared to what
they were
after they went through this drying
condition and you could see the leaf
microbes
if anything often grew even during these
wet conditions
the difference between the wet and the
dry was actually a net
increase in population some just kind of
held their population and only a few
were losers where they actually died and
lowered populations after they were wet
you compared that with say the rise of
their strength almost all of those
decreased the population size they died
by the time they got to the condition
that a cell would have seen in the real
world
so it appeared then that while many
micros might live on a plant
under these optimum conditions being wet
they do not have the capability of
of surviving in the plants when they
become dry and that might be one of the
conditions that really typifies an
epiphany
and another thing that we observed in
our early work with biological control
actually was that there is probably a
limitation of the rate of immigration of
microbes two leaves that dictates
the process of colonization
and it may be that only some microbes
are actually capable of growing on a
plant and they have to get those
particular microbes to a plant
before the colonization process can
start
we're going to look again at these
flowers remember they were virtually
sterile when they emerged
and you looked at flowers in the orchard
here
that the population size as a whole
increased after the flowers opened
only fairly slowly and even after a
couple of weeks the population sizes
had still not reached very high numbers
if we inoculated even just a few cells
of a good
plant colonists like pseudomonas
fluorescens you see that those
populations increased rapidly and the
population sizes
that these flowers could ultimately
harbor
about a million or so cells per flower
was one or two orders of magnitude
higher than they typically
did harbor at a given time so it was
like those flowers were sitting there
saying colonize may colonize me but they
couldn't
because the right immigrants didn't make
its way to the flower
to enable that process to start
so this kind of gives us some pause
about what is happening in the real
world and how it will differ in a
context-dependent way
i'm going to come back to this in a
minute but basically this is kind of the
way
many of the plants in the world now come
into the into
being from seeds and huge fields with
herbicides so that there's only in this
case little
corn seedlings with who knows where
any other kind of plant colonists would
ever make its way to these kind of
plants
compared to a more diversified setting
or even natural settings where you'd
have a lot of vegetation around at all
times
and a new plant coming into this world
is potentially going to have a
very different and probably a much
higher number of potential
immigrants so again leaf surfaces and
flowers are what we would call an
open microbiological habitat
you're going to think of these flowers
on these apple trees
where is the inoculum going to come from
to colonize those we know they're not
on the budge of the trees they're
certainly not in the flowers
but in this setting you see these cover
crop between these trees these grasses
in california they've been growing all
winter long they had
millions of bacteria on every little
leaf blade
they could easily move from this
vegetation nearby up into the trees
so how much in what role does
immigration play in this process
so we've been reintegrating interest in
this whole process of aerobiology and in
this
era of covid i think we all should be
kind of
interested in this and there's how many
microbes are moving around in
tiny particles in the air how important
is that in
human health or in this case what's the
role of these particles in the air in
terms of
plant colonization so we did a simple
experiment berkeley
right on the eastern edge of san
francisco bay from our lab we look at
through the golden gate bridge to the
pacific ocean and the air blows from the
west almost all the time towards
berkeley and it hasn't seen a plant
since the last
asia so we went down to the edges
by vacuuming air through our filters
and then we vacuumed the air at the same
location
but about 30 meters inland after the
eric passed over
some vegetation we're going to look at
the numbers and types of bacteria in the
air by
enumerating the dna signatures of the
microbes that we collected on those
filters
and it was striking to me anyway that
even after just
100 feet of you would 30 meters inland
from
the bay when the air first saw plants
that there was around six to ten times
more bacteria in the air
and when you looked at the types of
bacteria that we recovered on that air
and there's a whole group of different
bacterial taxes that you would typically
find in the air
and compare the upwind air with the
micros we recovered on the plants and
the
microbes that we found in the downwind
air
and you'll see that comparing this group
with this group that the downwind air
looks a lot more like the plants
and the downwind area doesn't look very
much like the upwind here
and that particular taxa like pentoya
which is a very prominent
plant colonizer is very abundant on
plants but also a major
factor in the downward air hardly
detectable in the upland air
so it really looks like the air just
being infused by these plant colonies
like sphingomonas same story
that the plants are releasing bacteria
very efficiently into the air
there is basically now a mobile
reservoir of these
oculum that could move around and then
those could then be deposited
onto other plants and it would then seem
like
even fat plants do vary in the types of
microbes that they do support and that
is true beans here have different ones
from grass and so on
that a given plant might have a very
different type of a microflora that
would eventually develop on it
as a function of what is the source of
inoculum
for that i'm not going to come to the
leaves to colonize
so i took it down into the fact that my
brother has
been a farmer in oregon where i grew up
he
grows uh grass in this case tall fescue
a crimson clover and wheat are some of
his major crops
grows them in large homogeneous steels
and so i took a particular target plant
in this case i took
uh tall fescue plants that grow on the
greenhouse
we transplanted them into the middle of
this tall fescue fields his clover
fields
his wheat fields and then came back a
few weeks later to look at the
communities that developed on that tall
fescue
and if the plant itself was really the
driver of what ended up
growing on the leaves of the tall fescue
we would have thought
that the toll fescue would have had
similar communities on it no matter
what its local environment was
but the pco plotted you see upper and
ever right
you'll see that the communities on the
grass
plants are very different from ones in
the clover and the ones in the wheat
that it was very very different that
there were different types of microbes
that could live
on tall fescue and it seemed then to be
driven by you know what was
the first and most organisms that would
be arriving
at that tall fiscu was going to be the
dominant colonizer
and this can fits into what another
group looking at seaweeds and
the ocean off of australia came up what
they call the competitory
competitive lottery bottle of community
assembly
and you can just read the bottom line
from their their
story showing that basically species
with similar ecological properties are
able to occupy the same dish
that is a variety of microbes can live
on leaf surfaces
and the ones that would end up being
there are going to be determined by this
stochastic recruitment the stochastic
recruitment to me
says the way we manage plants
management practices can have a huge
effect on the kind of communities we
find on our plants
and a practical implication of this has
been other work that we've been doing
and i won't show you all the results
but grapes grapes are a big deal in
northern california grapes are very
subject to freezing
temperatures in the spring there isn't
enough water available to
protect the plants against the freezing
we've been able to show that the
microbial communities and the grapes in
this
left-hand side of this large field where
we had removed the vegetation of
herbicide
were very different from the microbes
and the grapes when
we allowed the cover crops to grow in
this case there's many fewer isolating
bacteria here
than over here and that again simply by
changing the local
microbiological context of those plants
we can have a very
big effect on
vein we did a large experiment a few
years ago
a cooperating grower let us use about an
80 hectare or pear orchard we divide it
up into large numbers of relatively
large blocks
where we plant a particular species of
plants as cover crops under them
so we have a large randomized block just
part of what you see here
and we came back and we measured two
different things we measured
the amount of airborne bacteria within a
particular block
so each one of these little blocks was
about uh
three acres in size and there was five
replicas of each little block
so this is the number of bacterial cells
deposited per
petri dish per hour we brought up large
numbers of undergraduates and
we all synchronized our watches and at
the exact same time open them up for an
hour
in an area where there was different
mixed weeds and grasses
compared to where we'd remove the
vegetation or we had plants that didn't
support very many bacteria as epiphytes
it's interestingly just like we would
have shown from the
aerosol measurements with our dna
devices we see that there was something
like
four or five times more bacteria in the
air
in the areas where we had a lot of these
abundant
sources of bacteria such as grasses
pouring under the trees compared to the
trees
early on when there were not very many
bacteria and this
in turn had a very measurable effect on
in this case
fruit wrestling where these oxen
producing bacteria were
more abundant early in the development
of the plants
because of their sources on either the
localized plants nearby
let me just finish by one simple cartoon
showing that
the colonization of plants involves many
processes but these occur at very
different scales
in terms of who ends up on the plants
which are a big part of the story
this is a very large-scale phenomenon
where
immigration from one plant and
immigration another are
tied processes and these are happening
at very very large scales
you know from many meters to maybe
kilometers of the microbes in a
particular region
are going to differ and that's going to
be the sources of an outcome
for the for the process but after they
were to
land on a plant it saw at a very very
small scale
the bacteria probably do not care what's
happening even a few millimeters away
from each other
on a leaf and that everything that's
important to the process
is happening at these very very small
scales and that
the types of inoculum coming how much
interactions are happening between the
bacteria are happening at very very
small scales
well i just finished by making a plug
for what a lot of people are very
interested in these days
and it's kind of i'm going to call
agricultural probiotics
but i think it kind of makes that sit
back and look at the way we do
agriculture these days you saw a picture
of the
you know basically the large naked
cornfield there's a large
naked soybean field this is kind of the
way we do ag anymore large large large
fields
long distances from any other kind of
natural vegetation that
might be part of the normal process by
which colonization
happens and i think it's probably
inhibiting the establishment of a
normal microflora on these plants and if
the normal microflora is really
important in terms of competition
with plant pathogens that we're probably
making our plants
somewhat more susceptible to disease
kind of inadvertently
by having these effects on the community
as itself
and i think this is one of the reasons
why there's been the effects that we see
on from agricultural probiotics
inoculating seeds spraying different
things on the leaves
there's very often demonstrations that
we can
improve plant growth make them more
resistant to disease and all
by changing the microbiology and i think
that effect is even more pronounced and
probably dictates the need for some way
to intervene if we're going to
keep growing plants in this somewhat
artificial way
to kind of restore a normal microbiology
so to speak
well i'll stop there and just kind of
give acknowledgement to a lot of people
doing a lot of great work in the lab
and i guess we can answer any questions
if you have some
all right thanks so much steve um it was
really interesting
so for questions uh we have time for
maybe one or two and then i know that at
1 45
we have set aside for a student postdoc
um lunch or meet up or whatever
so if anyone has any questions and wants
to write them into the chat
or unmute yourself and ask you can go
ahead so a question from
uh joanne uh who asks
how might other leaf-dwelling microbes
for example fungi
affect or contribute to the behaviors
that you're describing for
bacteria very interesting question
i took out of my slides some pictures of
showing that
bacteria may actually exploit fungi for
growth
bacteria really don't penetrate leaves
very much they're kind of dependent on
this passive
diffusion of resources on the leaf
surface
but it's very common if you do see fungi
growing on leaf and many
certainly plant pathogenic bacteria have
fungi
have the ability to invade the interior
of the plant
bring resources up the fungal hyphae are
actually great places to see bacterial
growth so
there's this mycorrhizal just micro
sphere if you would that microbes fungi
bringing resources from the interior of
the plant to the surface
where bacteria can exploit them directly
so you got bacteria on plants
but you also have bacteria on fungi they
got the nutrients
from the plant so there are kind of
several trophic levels that can happen
here
and then i'll just i'll read this with
one more question that i'll
um i'll read and then i think we'll sort
of
wrap up um so you you mentioned that
most epiphytic epiphytes aggregate on
the leaf surface
and so what happens when a new
population of pathogen lands there
do they blend into the population
navigate through it with
nutrient competition or do they have to
fight and
sort of expel the local community to
establish exclusive territory around the
stomata
that's a very good question um it's
probably both of those things happening
as you
saw from the salmonella where it's it's
less likely that an
immigrant is going to survive at all if
they land on a naked part of the leaf
hey that part of the league probably
doesn't have any resources for growth in
the first place
you don't have this you know
modification of local environment
but obviously if they're going to end up
among other organisms they're going to
have to be successful competitors so
there will be this probably intense
competition
in many places where a pathogen would in
fact land on a leaf if they didn't
themselves get a tone
all right great um so i think with that
let's um
thank steve again and then for the
students or postdocs interested in
attending this next session we can
transition over to that
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu